i'd like to address the millions of
canadians who are making responsible
decisions to ensure their safety and the
safety of their loved ones
i know that this this pandemic has been
frustrated after two years the battle
against covet 19 is still dominating so
many parts of our lives
this virus
affects us all
two of my own children have now
contracted it
and this morning i learned i
i tested positive for covid19 as well
i feel well
and have no symptoms
of course i'll be working remotely this
week and we'll keep following public
health guidelines
i want to take this opportunity to
remind canadians to please get
vaccinated
it's a challenge that my family and i
are facing but there's nothing unusual
or special about it it's a challenge too
many canadians and people around the
world
know all too well
this pandemic
continued our health care workers are
continuing to work very hard
scientists are working day and night
that we can get vaccines to keep us safe
endemic is not over and we have to be
there for one another
and as we continue to have each other's
backs as we steal ourselves for the
challenges ahead
i know you're wondering about what you
saw in our capital city this weekend
as my friend irwin cutler said on
saturday
freedom of expression assembly and
association are cornerstones of
democracy
but nazi symbolism racist imagery and
desecration of war memorials
are not
it is an insult
to memory and truth
hate
can never
be the answer
over the past few days canadians were
shocked and frankly
disgusted
by the behavior displayed by some people
protesting in our nation's capital
i want to be very clear
we are not
intimidated
by those who hurl insults and abuse at
small business workers and steal food
from the homeless
we won't give in
to those who fly racist flags
we won't cave
to those who engage in vandalism or
dishonor the memory of our veterans
the statute terry fox
statue of terry fox and the two of the
honest unknowns are not only symbols
allowed us to build
or to spread hateful messages
i want to thank the many canadians
who've made donations to the shepherds
of good hope and to the terry fox
foundation in response
to what they saw this weekend
there is no place in our country
for threats
violence or hatred
so to those responsible for this
behavior
it needs to stop
to anyone who joined the convoy but is
rightly uncomfortable with the symbols
of hatred and division on display
join with your fellow canadians be
courageous
and speak out
do not stand for
or with
intolerance and hate
us
difficult times leadership all
politicians need to show responsibility
to the politicians exploiting people's
fears
i ask you
to think long and hard
about the consequences of your actions
to the nearly 90 percent of truckers
across the country who've gotten
vaccinated who continue working hard to
keep us fed and keep our economy moving
thank you
truckers have tough jobs
long hours on the road
days away from their families
real challenges particularly over the
past two years as they've continued to
step up
to put food on our shelves and on our
tables
to support us with life-saving
medication and supplies
we have relied on you
and you can rely on us to continue to
stand with you and allow you to do your
jobs safely
almost 90 percent of you
are doing exactly that right
exactly that
and we thank you
deeply
for everything you've done
the behavior on display this weekend
does not
represent you
and to canadians at home
watching and disgust and disbelief at
this behavior wondering how this could
have happened in our nation's capital
after everything we've been through
together
this is not the story of our pandemic
of our country of our people
canada is strong
because you
huge sacrifices for nearly two years
you've been there for each other as
neighbors
friends
and fellow canadians
i think of the moms and dads
who looked after their families
the kids who stepped up
in so many different ways
seniors
who stayed strong in our darkest days
volunteers throughout our communities
who supported our most vulnerable
frontline workers from truckers to store
clerks who've kept our shelves stocked
and made sure we have food on our tables
healthcare heroes
who've saved countless lives
and continue to do so
we know you're tired
and yet
you do not stop
you inspire us
canadians
support you
we're in your corner
all of you
you
are the story of this pandemic
not the convoy
said pandey me
too silly
or
vaccinations for children i will
continue to be there for you
i wish i could tell you
that there are no
more difficult moments ahead
but we all know i can't say that
what i can say
is that this government
will continue to have your backs
we will continue to be there for you as
long as it takes
with as much as it takes
that's how we've all gotten through this
pandemic so far and that's what we
and i
will continue to focus on
because we believe in you
canadians
are compassionate
kind
strong
and resilient
you elected us all to get big things
done and with the return of parliament
we all have work to do
later today
i'll be participating in question period
an important part of our democratic
system alongside parliamentarians who
despite threats and intimidation
will continue to serve you
canadians and work together to deliver
results for people
this afternoon we'll be introducing
legislation to ensure we continue
providing as many rapid tests as
possible to the provinces and
territories
and tonight
i'll be virtually addressing the house
of commons about the situation in
ukraine
are we talking about the importance of
freedom
democracy
and the rule of law
in the face of russian provocation
in this difficult time
more than ever
we must stay true to our values
to who we are as canadians
as canadians
we stand up for what's right
and mostly
we stand up for each other
that's how we've gotten through this so
far
that's how we'll continue
to get through this
that's how we remain
true to who we are
thank you friends thank you prime
minister when i'll start the question
period for 20 minutes starting with the
phone today
thank you misty please press tarwan at
this time if you have a question
the first question
is prince
please go ahead
yeah good afternoon i'm wondering a lot
of the
leaders or organizers of this convoy
have asked to
meet or at least hear from you about
what's happening in their demand have
you or will you or anyone from your
government meet with them or negotiate
with them in any way
my focus
is standing with canadians and getting
through this pandemic the way to get
through this pandemic
is to continue
making the challenging choices and
sacrifices as citizens as individuals as
communities
to keep each other safe
to trust science to trust facts
to continue being there for each other
that is my focus that is what i will
stay focused on
can you explain the reason why want to
participate or meet with them i mean
you've attended uh rallies on the hill
in the past
including during a black lives matter
protest um and others is there a reason
that you can give as for why you will
not
discuss or have any negotiations with
this particular group
i have attended protests and rallies in
the past
when i agreed with the goals when i
supported the people
expressing their concerns and their
issues black lives matter is an
excellent example of that
but i have also chosen to not
go anywhere near protests that have
expressed hateful rhetoric
violence towards fellow citizens
and a disrespect
not just of science but of the frontline
health workers and quite frankly the 90
of truckers who have
been doing the right thing to keep
canadians safe to put food on our tables
canadians know where i stand this is a
moment for responsible leaders to think
carefully
about where they stand and who they
stand with
operations
next question thank you
and to
public
some people have accused you of
politicizing the question of mandatory
vaccination during the election campaign
what would you say to those who say that
you share part of the responsibility for
the anger that we've seen over this
issue
not only do we have a higher vaccination
rate than many of our countries
uh
our fellow
the next question is from tom perry from
cbc news please go ahead
hi prime minister thanks for taking our
questions um supporters of this movement
will say that it's a small minority of
people in this protest who are causing
trouble so is it fair to focus in on the
obviously terrible behavior of some and
paint all protesters with that brush
i think
obviously the the right to free
expression the right to assembly the
right to uh make your displeasure known
in a democracy
is extraordinarily important and needs
to be heeded and respected
but there have been many many
protests
over uh over the past years that i've
seen
that i've been
part of that i've watched from a
distance
on parliament hill and elsewhere
where people come together angry about a
certain thing wanting something else to
change
that
don't see the level
of hateful rhetoric
of swastikas
of abuse towards their fellow citizens
there is always a right
to protest peacefully that i and others
will defend fully as part of this
democracy there is not a right to incite
violence
to perform acts of violence
or to spew hatred
and i think
anyone who
is
part of this group
who is disgusted
by what their uh what the folks
protesting alongside are doing
needs to step up and take responsibility
condemn these actions
and look for other ways to express their
displeasure
you talk about politicians exploiting
people's fears who are you talking about
and what impact do you think they're
having
i think all politicians need to think
very carefully
about who they're supporting about what
messages they're putting out we have
seen
over the past
many many months conservative police
politicians
sharing disinformation about vaccines
encouraging conspiracy theories online
and i think aaron o'toole
is going to need to reflect very
carefully
on how he's walking a path
that supports uh these people who do not
represent truckers let alone
the vast majority of canadians
operator next question
thank you
do you intend to make any concessions to
these truckers
is
i'm not going to focus on the protesters
who
don't respect science
evidence or in some cases our democratic
principals
vaccination mandates for truckers on
their side as well
whether our policies were aligned with
the americans or
now there are some situations where we
were very well aligned with the us and
we worked very closely together and in
other cases that was left
but i have always insisted that each
country had to make its own decisions
it shouldn't be a surprise
the same types of policies are in place
to protect themselves next question
thank you let me see the next question
from sundance charles stefano
please go ahead
yes prime minister you um said that uh
aaron o'toole has to think carefully but
he did meet with um some truckers on
friday
um
do you think that was an inappropriate
gesture of support to
tucker as
specifically
about anyone else
in terms of his process and he speaks to
mexi's
participation
as part of our job as politicians every
single day
we make decisions about
who to meet with
who to respond to how to respond to them
who to engage with
how
not just our engagements but
our example
impacts on public discourse
if uh we choose to
put up with
and tacitly support
conspiracy theorists
and uh folks peddling disinformation
that's a reflection on uh what we choose
to do as politicians and who we are as
leaders
obviously
i'm
going to trust in canadians
understanding of
the kind of responsible leadership that
is needed right now
and i'm sure canadians are watching what
all politicians are doing right now and
remembering
who is choosing to stand up for what and
for whom
and what choices they are making as
leaders i think through this pandemic
canadians
have seen and have a right to expect
responsible leadership
and unfortunately
that's not what we've always seen from
the likes of erin o'toole or even more
maxim bernie
following up
um given the behavior you outlined today
what do you want to see the security
forces on parliament hill and in
downtown ottawa do about the situation
first of all i'd like to make sure that
uh people are safe first and foremost
that small businesses restaurants uh in
ottawa can get back to work
that
citizens can go to their jobs that
parliamentarians
can continue to do the important work
of serving canadians of upholding our
democracy
yes
there is a right to protest there is a
right to make your voices heard loudly
and clearly
there is not a right
to shut down our democracy or our
democratic processes there is not a
right to abuse intimidate and harass
your fellow citizens
who are trying to go about their
business trying to live their lives and
not necessarily in agreement with what
you are doing
good afternoon
mandate
for those who want to travel
the uh mandate for trucker only applies
to the us canada border
follow-up question
is this something that's still on the
table
that is good
if it is do you not think that this
might add fuel to the to the flames
on this
nearly 90 destructors are already
vaccinated
we know that
even without additional mandates
domestic mandates
most people are doing the right thing
rather than speculating about possible
next steps that may be possible in the
future or may not
operate our next question thank you
melty next question merica wash the
globe
hi prime minister thanks for taking our
um call today i just want to follow up
on
um
victoria i'm gonna mute my phone i'm
just trying to follow up on some of your
your responses about the protesters i
understand the concerns around um many
of the actions for many of the
protesters but i'm wondering if you as
the prime minister need to engage with
the fears and the concerns that others
in the crowd raise about the vaccine
there seems to be a real concern for
many of them about the safety of that
vaccine and i'm wondering if you are
avoiding addressing that by only
focusing on
the
much more hateful and nefarious elements
of the protest this weekend
marika anyone who thinks that i haven't
been talking about how safe vaccines are
has been listening to everything i've
been saying over the past two years
vaccines are safe and effective
the way we get through
the way we get through this public
health crisis
get back to the things we love
is by trusting science
by trusting the facts
by uh being there for each other by
stepping up for each other
we have been hearing people hesitant
about getting vaccinated for well over a
year now and we have been reaching out
to them community by community
individual by individual
at at the highest level uh but also uh
in interpersonal contacts
to reassure people that vaccines are
safe and effective
and that they are the way to get through
this pandemic
so yes the concerns
expressed by a few people
gathered in ottawa right now
are
not new not surprising
are heard
but are a continuation of what we've
unfortunately seen
in
disinformation and misinformation online
conspiracy theorists uh about microchips
about you know god knows what else that
go with the tinfoil hats
we
have been clear
every step of the way
that the work our frontline health
workers the work our scientists and
researchers are doing the people at
health canada the people working on
these vaccines all around the world
is the work that will get us through
this get us back to the things we love
operator last question
the protesters are talking about freedom
was by being there for each other that's
what defines
what being canadian is
marginalized
so while this fringe minority
is protesting
we all want to be done with this
pandemic
but the vast majority of canadians
very well know
but the way out
manifesto is
is the parliamentary precinct
uh safe yeah
do we need more uh police
the security public i have enormous
faith
are
and i know that canadians across the
country
trust that these people will serve the
public good operator would it be
possible to uh put marika walsh on the
on the line she didn't get her follow-up
perfect thank you
and we don't have america wash in the
queue anymore i'm sorry
thank you this is what ends today's
press conference
merci talmud
thank you everyone
you